[Music]
hey welcome to windows Wednesday this is
gonna be a very very interesting case
study of a cuckold Stuart brown I met
Stuart Brown when he was working in the
corporate world as a CFO six-figure
salary but really wanted to get out and
do property over the last couple of
years we worked closely together
he's now financially free he's got his
full-time in property he's got a
beautiful portfolio that he's built up
and we're gonna be learning the lessons
the struggles the successes and I think
this would be a real good one so Stuart
thank you so much for coming down to the
office it's my pleasure good to see you
and yourself this has been one of the
longest winners Wednesday's in the
making probably because we've been
talking about in this persona but you
really want to just wait until the right
time yeah I want to see cash in the bank
right that's the acid test I think yeah
I wanted to get to that well you're a
CFO so you you're a numbers guy yeah and
even when rent starts coming in you want
to make sure that it's stable it's
coming in properly that all prop all the
properties are set up and established
well and then and then you in position
where you can say I've done it
absolutely
so why don't you start from the
beginning what's your background and why
did you want to get out of the corporate
world
yeah sure well as you say I'm a CFO
chief financial officer and I've worked
in the corporate world with private
equity people basically helping
businesses realize what create value and
realized value and done that for a long
time and I helped her business turn
around
sell it and ultimately got asked to stay
on and run that operation great and I
loved it absolutely loved it and then
about four or five years ago we are the
head office come in and say do you know
what you did a great job but we're gonna
move you to a different country and
we're gonna close it down and that was a
heartbreaker absolute heartbreak because
I've got 150 people looking at me on my
own you know future etcetera so I found
that really that was a chance that took
some time to get over and one of the
things that when I went through that
journey it said to me you know what I
need to start making a bit of money for
myself
not just be in a corporate and a
corporate role why don't I start trying
to make a bit of money for myself no
idea what I was gonna do not not at all
and yeah fast forward and I was sat on a
Sun Lounger on a holiday
and I came across this book Rich Dad
Poor Dad and you know that book and if
if anybody's watching this and hasn't
read that book just read that book
because it will change your life we've
got that Porter Robert Keyes like it's
amazing it's absolutely
honestly I read that book I was like man
I missed that class yeah unbelievable
like like most people what I did when I
was younger my mom and dad you know
you've got to work hard you've got to go
to uni you've got to get a job and I did
all that it was very successful I read
that book and I was like whoa yeah hang
on a minute there's another way of doing
this it was a bit of a break the matrix
moment it was like wow and I literally
finished that book sat on that Sun
Lounger and the next thing I did in
Amazon was when property investment and
up came this book by this guy called
Samuel Leeds who what never aired up
that said by low rent hi and I thought
right okay they said and I started
reading that book and the thing that
struck me about that book was like this
is a real how-to book it's not just kind
of general stuff like you reading a lot
of books it's real hard to detail do
this do that do the other side
man this is a like a blueprint for what
Kiyosaki is talking about Wow so I read
that book I got right to the end and I
remember the moment so clearly it said
connect with me on Facebook and that one
of those key moments in your life where
I almost just put it down and went my
I'll get around to it but I didn't there
and then on that song lounge it I
connected with you and then bang you
connect you came straight back to this
was a couple years ago and was kind of
yeah Stu you need to come to this thing
called the crash course okay do it right
fine and wow that that was I mean it was
a different I mean it was a different
scale that compared to what you're doing
now but like maybe two three
yeah exactly now there's like a thousand
exactly but water what an experience and
again another lightbulb moment I
remember this so clearly you were there
with your flip chart and you're talking
about these things called HMOs which I'd
never heard of and he just drew up the
numbers 800 passed cash flow and it was
like boom really Wow amazing I'll never
forget that moment anyways they're like
a light bulb going off it was incredible
and I remember the crash course it was
we connected didn't we quiet year we had
quite a special moment really I tell you
that I went there with my family and
with my I've three children and my son
was with me and again and one of those
key key moments where we we'd had the
crash course and you would say you know
there's going to be certain people that
I'm kind of happy to work with etc come
to the back if you kind of want to have
a discussion and I was a little bit
woman in our--in about it and I remember
Misun it was like dad what you doing
come on we need to get you need to do
this you want to do this come on and he
really pushed us together and I signed
up there and then and it occurred to me
that evening that you know it's not just
for me this is kind of for my family as
well so I remember saying to you would
you mind if you know I also had my son
joy and you were like oh yeah that'd be
amazing that'd be great so we you were
like should we get old I steal this on
stage so Richard had no idea I remember
it so well and he came up on stage and
we you know we kind of gifted him that
thing and it was like special yeah it's
not cheap education no it's not
thousands of pounds yeah exactly and
yeah so it was a big investment for me
and then I've been got over that I
doubled it up and Wow
you know and I'm from asan as well if
you look if you read the Kiyosaki book
you hear about good debt bad debt and he
won't mind me saying it but he's had a
little bit of bad debt opportunity yeah
in his life and I saw this as an
opportunity for him to be able to also
build on yes own success I mean doctor
growing is extremely successful in his
own right but I saw that as another
opportunity as well if I remember
because Richard is an awesome awesome
guy he you know grow into a bit bad debt
and things like that and you could have
just bailed him out but you were you
really wanted him to get the education
himself to be able to work himself out
of it if I remember definitely that's
dose to I mean he's fair to say the
banker dad has played a part in his in
all my you know as you do because he put
a lot of genesis but you I definitely
wanted him to learn as well yes grown
what about when we had a mentorian
session yeah I mean that was he and I
and that was very moving as well and for
me personally you know I've got things
that I wanted to accomplish and yeah it
was another special moment and for me
actually
I mean I'm gonna say thank you to you
big target at the end of this book it's
not just been about property it's been a
life experience it's been a it's
absolutely been a transition yeah from
my point of view yes it's been very very
special from properties the vehicle
isn't it that's exactly what it is that
is all is I mean quite frankly property
to me I can take it or leave it I don't
get excited about it it's it's the
numbers at the end of the day and then
execute it on it but it's purely a
vehicle and it's a vehicle that can just
it can just fundamentally change things
on a scale that you just can't imagine
yeah so yeah we re joined up and I would
say that was kind of probably early 2018
and I would say 2018 was probably our
classes kind of a year of education yeah
so DfE all the different courses and the
Academy yeah on the Academy and you know
you you and that's so important I would
say to anybody
number one you need a vision you've got
to have some vision of where you want
get to but number two you've got to
understand you need education you just
have to have education and I would say
education in two ways mindset and
technicals yeah and those technical
aspects probably this guy he's got it
all you got it all you know all of these
things all these strategies things I've
never heard of and that year for me was
educating those technical things I
needed to understand and do and also
getting your mindset right as well
because you know when you used to earn
in a significant salary you're used to
being in corporate world yeah it's a
different kind of mindset yeah so that's
been a process as well that's a journey
that you go on of self development what
would you say the key differences are
between the mindset of someone in the
corporate world and then that because I
know you've got out of that yeah what
what what are the difference is how's
life different I think I think it
depends on the individual but I would
say that when you're in corporate
whether you're in a job then you
basically go work for somebody else and
you get a salary and and it's it's quite
it can be quite low risk actually it is
quite honestly and when you're in when
you start to make that transition you've
got to be prepared to take some risks
and you've got to be able to kind of
stay the course and keep going and keep
taking action and I mean one of the one
of the one of the very real differences
is if you're in if you're in a job
you're gonna be following somebody's
rules yeah at the end of the day and
that's fine and when you are it you kind
of worked your own rules you have your
own values and all of those things but
yeah it's definitely different because
some people will probably say oh it's
alright for you Stuart because you know
you're on a good salary
you had you know money which some people
doubt would wear this by now but I
actually think that it's nothing harder
when you're on a six-figure salary and
you in the corporate world because
number one you're working like a dog
yeah it's hard you were working for 100
hours away you see you you work you've
got absolutely no time exactly and one
of the things like I know you learns
probably in the hard way you can't throw
money at people in the property world to
do stuff or you know got to learn how to
eat yourself that's true once you know
how to do it yourself you can then
outsource it yeah yeah but I know you
got burned by sources yeah definitely
because because it's easy just put I'll
just history grand history grounds in
the area but you can't really do that no
and the second reason it's harder is
because transitioning from corporate
world to full-time in property which you
are now to leave a six-figure job if
you're if you're if you're working on as
demand you getting paid fifteen hundred
pound a month well you can replace that
like that but when you're comfortable
with having a holiday a couple holidays
a year two nice cars big half mortgage
family who's depending on you who have
also become accustomed to a certain
lifestyle and you're the breadwinner of
the family it's actually a lot of
pressure and I think it's often people
in that situation there's struggle the
most to do what you've done
yeah and I think I think that's really
true and I think being practical about
it you have to kind of do it or beliefs
for me step by step so although it's
very easy to say yeah I'm really busy
and I am working really hard which are
which true
yeah the reality is even though I didn't
used to take a lunch at the reality is
you can carve out a little bit of time
in the day in your lunch hour and you
can do a bit of search on the internet
yeah you can actually start to look at
some properties yeah you can actually go
and book some viewings for the Saturday
and that's probably what I did to start
with I literally just carved a little
bit of time out wheelchair or when I got
home I would just be on Rightmove and
just trying to find a deal yeah and then
I'd go and view it and then it kind of
builds from there yeah so so how many
properties and I know a lot of them I
hate you know
some of them a very profitable how many
of you got you bought further now so HMO
wise that's my strategy
I'll never forget that why would you
write not that that is absolutely my
core strategy so right now I have four I
have another one completing all being
it's supposed to be tomorrow but I think
it'll actually be beginning of next week
that's thank you have another one
completing at the end of October and I'm
just challenging myself a little bit
more because I was kind of thinking well
I'll do two a quarter I've decided
that's not quick enough now so we're
going to do four in this quarter so I've
got these three two that we've nailed
down one that we've just had a 207 we
gotta prove we got agreed offer on just
this week and there's one yeah number
service so we've got you put that on the
Academy yeah yeah there's no seven
agreed so we got it we've got it let's
take the four yeah yeah just off those
for me I know you're gonna be on number
seven very soon but how much something
can we get yeah okay so I've got it I
just feel I want to share this with you
not only do you not only can you get
paid income you can actually get paid
where do you buy the property in other
words you can get more money back than
you paid out talk to me about that
oh man this is this like the first two
properties I did the first two HMOs were
I left some money in fair enough okay
fine well you say left so many things
that there's done my research okay yeah
so it was about that big okay so the
view you've kind of combined we have -
hey Timon course with a BRR I know I
kind of combined that yeah yeah so sweet
spots okay so let's do a I'll talk about
it so basically when I started out I
looked for a picked an area I went to
figure out what the rules of the game
were in that area of course so all the
things that you teach you know is it
article four or not okay this area is
not fine go to look at the castle
website figure out the little rules blah
blah blah and I went to look for a
residential house of a certain size that
was that I that was in a pool let's say
not a great condition that I could
convert
from residential to HMO without any
planning permission
that was the basic thing and I wanted to
kind of add some value to it so
basically you purchase the property and
for all those people out there that's
thinking oh I can't afford it etc etc
well there are ways to do that which
this guy is very well-versed in and we
we acquired a particular property then
we did some development on it etc etc
and with the idea that once we'd done it
it would be a able to rent out by the
room yeah and be would be able to
refinance it so on that particular the
very first one we did I think we'd paid
78 for I think we spend I don't know it
was in it was in the region of 40 or
something I forget the figures it was
quite a bit but I remember because I see
it on the cash flow statement all the
time we left in it 21 on that deal so
when you say left in what you moved you
then once you'd you'd bought it you will
then add value yeah and then you
refinance correct so the mortgage people
will give you a certain amount of cash
back based on the valuation and when so
cash out cash back so the return on
investment then on that first deal 28
percent 28 percent yeah and actually
that's conservative because my strategy
personally from a hey Chavo point view
is I'll always buy five room five
multiple rooms or six all my port fellow
at the moment is actually five and I'll
conservatively assume that I'm going to
get four out of the five rooms let and
on a conservative basis for rooms let
typically is going to cash flow you
about five hundred a month twelve five
to six gram six grand over the twenty
grand it's around about twenty eight
percent yes and that is very
conservative it is because the moment
you do five rooms let which obviously is
the goal boom you're up at eight hundred
which was your board that you drew and
Shido then you're talking eight nine
grand or any but you're talking fifty
percent return on capital employed yeah
and when you look at the bank and you
getting half a percent go
you know it's like that it's incredible
so that I cut my teeth on that to out to
your question about not leaving any
money in the third HMO that we did was
by far the best so far
so that one we bought for actually was a
two-bedroom house believe it or not and
it had a huge bathroom so when I walk
around it I thought well okay good
maybe we can do a bit of jiggery-pokery
here and we can create a third bedroom
upstairs still create a bathroom to
electable rooms downstairs got that
house 461 ground which was a steal a
steal 61 I think after refurbishment we
are all in on that property at 94 30
krandalls yeah but with fees and all of
that stuff that you have to do so yeah
you know before stampers you've seen
everything
so I think the refurb was something
around about the 25 more than you stand
18 fees all in probably 94 not probably
is 94 and we've refinanced that with a
value of one three five will call out
103 so that properties paid me so I went
to choose that property I put some cash
in somebody's give me some cash back
it's 9 grand cash in the bank I got paid
you have a process you got paid nine
thousand pounds no problem I'll see
credible I do that and I remember you
talking about this kind of you know you
know money down or you know money left
didn't deal and you know it's kind of
the Holy Grail but I have absolutely
seen it mmm and it's all about what your
book said by low rent high and and you
make your money when you buy yeah well
usually I think that's that's the case
incredible deal it's awesome how many
bedrooms is that it's fine now so you
know a cash flow we do at 500 a month if
I suit for rooms 800 if I if I get the
full five yeah awesome deal it's so cool
we did that on HMO 3 HMO for same thing
we bought that one will refinance it and
I think that will pay me 3 grand and
once the financing all
in other words cash are these bombs
they're all in Hall okay I thought
that's the golden question they're all
but the thing is though halls not the
magic area because you can do this just
about any way well everybody will tell
you that everybody I've ever met Sean
Hall really you know it's this it's that
it's the other and I would say in that
particular area you're not gonna get
you'll not get the same capital
appreciation as you will protect you in
other areas so it's agree though so it's
so investing a lot yeah it's okay for
cash flow
yeah it's there's no it's not as good
for people say to me they say what's
your golden area and there isn't a
golden area they've gotta find an area
you got a make it golden with education
and and it it is that and like you said
earlier I've made mistakes and learnings
on the way and what I would say to
people is when you pick whatever they
whatever the area is and okay I've said
Hall where I've made some don't think oh
yeah need to shout and do you call it
it's not that at all no it isn't and I
know people are lost money oh yeah
exactly you need to pick you need to
decide on the particular area that that
you want to go for and and then you need
to do your due diligence and and uh and
you write about you've got to get in the
water and you've really got to swim and
understand it and I made mistakes early
on so I did you know I followed the
speak to the HMO managers speak to these
people and Adalind there was to
postcodes in hall that would work and I
invested in one of them and then I
learned later on it wasn't as good as
perhaps you the one yeah and then I also
learned the there are certain streets
that have been of them on the streets
and yeah and and it's that kind of nice
not to put anybody off I just say yeah
do you do diligence and the other thing
went with people listening to this as
well I really want to say is you can do
all your education if you but you've
just got to do it it really is not that
difficult to take action
you literally I was talking to somebody
the other day it was asking me well
how'd you do this and work and I was
saying to the right just establish is
the area article for
article four that's dead easy to do just
go on the castle website just do that
yeah just do it then after that just
google the website and have a look and
go what's the rules because there are
little rules they're all pretty similar
they'll all have room sizes but there
are a little nuances for easy Aryan so
go on and find those rules out and then
just go on Rightmove
and just look at how many actual deals
are there are loads of deals you don't
even have to like this just loads then
you just pick the eight talk to the
agent and you start going to do some
viewings and you start to understand
what those numbers are yeah that's the
key I think you've gotta get your
numbers right yeah and then you can take
the four properties then yes yeah I work
on a couple of grand for those four
properties so it's not amazing you know
500 quid a piece very conservative it is
because you could say it's 800 apiece
and that's three thousand two you know
three thousand quid but it's a
conservative of two thousand pounds or
not oh yeah and then you've also got
three other properties you're about to
go through plus plus another one before
Christmas we will do that yeah live a
long time it's a full time income Italy
so it's not what I used to be earning
but what I have that will happen yeah so
we're gonna get to we're going to take
this I think well not I don't think I
know we're gonna take this to ten
properties at all yeah that's that's a
given and we've got people and Haise
amazing actually the more you put
yourself out there people come to you in
a lot would you like this would you like
yeah it's amazing and then we're just in
the process of picking a second area so
we're gonna do another ten in that
second area where's that I honestly
don't know I am found it I literally
don't know what a that's what I was
doing yesterday afternoon I was looking
at a map of England and establishing
which article for well yeah I'm
absolutely in the process of deciding
what that area is going to be so and I
would say how are you gonna find out
it's gonna be well hit by the sounds of
it
you just keep going recycle any money
exactly and what in refurnished pulling
the money out dr. Shannon again again
and again and that's it it's I look for
and I would say that people you can
don't not stop you just need to stop but
that is what I do look for I look for
opportunities that where you can
genuinely add some value and then
recycle you can and then you can just go
again and go again and go again and I
again this week's been a bit of a
strategy week this week actually if I'm
honest because we'd be kind of working
on the business this week instead of
idiot so that's a decision we've made
ten in Hall ten somewhere else dawn and
when you were working in your corporate
job I remember when I was saying to you
you know I was encouraging you to quit
yeah and we went to Africa yeah we
didn't even talk about we went to
Barcelona we didn't yeah it was about
right okay so this guy will say to you
you make one move I'll make ten that's
so true I remember being in some way
down south somewhere on Devon Devon yeah
so we've gone down to David and Samuel
was saying okay everybody what you doing
what she what's the dream and so on and
so forth and I was like well I want to
live life on my own terms I want to
travel I want to buy some toys and I
want to teach pay was like okay well we
could figure out travel and teach right
now if you want oh can we all right cool
he was you know why don't you come to
Africa with us and that was amazing yeah
absolutely amazing so yeah and you've
had a workshop because most people say
to me I want to get on your stage I
didn't wanna be at the crash course and
teach and I said look if you want to
teach I'll bring you out to Zambia or
Uganda and you can teach you
it was so cool and you know it was up I
mean that that whole experience was just
unreal I mean obviously very challenging
and upsetting because of what happened
to yourself with my accident with her
accident and for all of us it was and I
felt it as well it was like
what are we gonna do now you know he's
not with us and it feels a bit further
doesn't know we on the second day of the
trip I broke my leg and you did it and
we were all very worried we were very
down and I remember you been in hospital
and in fact we don't you do some warrior
work with us the the preceding day of
you know being a warrior and what that
means
and yeah we kind of did all that in you
know in the nice surroundings if this
boat but I did feel really good about it
and they're like next day Wow
nice like cool you know and so but that
was character building yeah and was an
incredible experience because I got to
teach I actually fractured my arm as
well a few days later just just because
I've just to share the love and but
still got up on stage still did that
teaching in love that so much and the
people that you were teaching young
budding entrepreneurs in the wrong
remote parts of the gander Africa it was
amazing and then you know after we done
that the icing on the cake we went to
South Africa we had dinner with Robert
Kiyosaki so of course for me he's like
my hero yeah you Kiyosaki heroes so I'm
like wow that that was incredible and in
very intimate dinner hard was it was it
was unbelievable and I still loved that
little picture with me obvious a book
page because I just yes like worship
that guy that book is just gotta buy
that book it's yeah so yeah we we've
come just come such a long way and I I
feel so good actually Indy about where
we are at at the moment so yeah I'm
learning less but I'm living life on my
own terms
yeah and the reality is gonna be that we
are going to get back to where we were
before yeah and we've just finished our
cash flow strategy I was I was just
talking about and then we're going to do
some cash strategy as well so we started
to look for some plots of land mm-hmm
and
looking at doing some new build I have a
my best friend actually so as a builder
and we've been we offer obviously
shooting the breeze and we're not doing
this yeah I could do this so I'm really
looking forward to finish it off kind of
2019 with a hmo's that's just going to
happen
so you're owning less now than you were
but it's passive rather than active the
thing is you see and this is some one
thing else I share with people is when
you start out on your journey when you
in your 20s or at least for me you're
kind of going up the corporate world you
want to earn more you want more and you
end up spending more actually and you
end up putting yourself in kind of bad
debt you know things that are in reality
yeah really an asset they just they just
catch out every yeah
and then when you start to realize that
what I actually need to don't know I
don't mean live a life of being frugal
but just live a reasonable life you
start to figure out it's not it's not
that high actually so last couple years
in particular what I was in corporate
world I was I actually made a conscious
decision to call my salary up into a few
little pots and there was a big was
quite a big chunk of it I just stuck
over here
yeah because I I genuinely and I have
don't mean this to sound wrong but it
wasn't I don't need that to purely live
all of them yes and so you know for me
living on what I'm living on at the
moment you know it's not much money per
se but and I've got a little bit there
that it's kind of behind me so that goes
down and has comes up so yeah you know
it's not it's not like I'm gonna be no
paupers like nothing at all but that is
the journey that we're on and I don't
mind taking that you know it's that
transition that's the period that were
in at the moment yeah and you know I
absolutely know without a shadow of a
doubt the you know by Christmas were
like those HMOs I know if we shadow the
debt we'll have another
you will will go and do some big deals
yeah and there'll be a point in 2020
when I've had another chat with you
going yeah we did that yeah and you know
what I used to be anything in corporate
world yeah I'm living life on your own
terms
yeah that's so important that are you
happier now than you were yes
hey there happiest you've been a long
time yes yeah how's your son oh I need
to share this story with you so this is
so cool
he's great he's as you know he got
married he's now got two children but
the property thing that's happened to
him is so cool so I've never heard of
this concept like to buy before never in
a bit at all I thought if you had a
house and you needed to move ass you'd
have to sell the house then buy another
house well you don't have to do that and
so my son is just basically he got a
house that was till two down in our
village and it's gone up it's and
volleying he's doing a deal whereby he's
got a left to buy a mortgage so he's
allowed now to let that house a squeeze
but not to keep it and then he's been
out to fire this new house now this new
house is a bit of a BnB job it needs
some work doing to it fantastic in fact
tomorrow as well as Wednesday he does
always what am I thinking
on Saturday he's got me up there to
knock a wall down which we're doing and
we're just gonna that house is gonna be
worth a lot of money and we did the
maths on all of this a few months ago
and he is gonna be he'll have gone from
being where he was from a financial
standpoint to being in a equity positive
yeah situation yeah now that is amazing
it really is I'm so happy for it so
proud of it when you and you see the
EC's kids you know and they've got this
now that goes
big house you know it's just brilliant
so that that time when I first met you
and we were on that crash course and I
was thinking about for me I yeah I want
to be doing something different what my
son to be having something different
that's Derek to you you made that happen
honestly you absolutely no way would I
have been able to without that education
and without that support man no I really
appreciate that on a suit and that's why
we'd worry do these shows just because
like I get it I get a kick out of that
you know I always said to your success
is my oxygen and that's the truth yeah
this this Jude yeah these times and this
journey that we're all it's like right
there welded into my head about everyone
see you do you you figures on your HMO
be on stage with rich go to Africa yeah
carrying on on this journey being able
to call you up for some support
sometimes people say to me you know are
you favorite it be favoritism with this
person or warrior but the thing is you
know how I work I'm an investor an
investor of property on the mystery of
people and the reason I say you make one
move on 810 is because if I invest you
roll the same courses that I stare you
we trained ivalice there and it didn't
he buy a house next door to yours but
you put money in and he bought it on a
lease option agreement but the thing is
though the reasons been so much tell me
you guys with united stairs it's because
when you learn something you go and do
it you were in a corporate job but you
were you were booking the holiday tom
you didn't have any holidays no I made
that Africa trip that that I literally
asked work for two weeks awful pain
unpaid because you used all your holiday
on academy training I
you did Ryu's everyday for it kind of
betrayed yeah and then you had to take
unpaid leave to go to Africa so you know
quick credit to you and you deserve
every everything you ever everything
you've got you've worked for when you
deserve and I'm really honored to be
part of the journey so thanks so much my
name is Samuel Leeds thank you for
watching winners on a Wednesday every
single week we interview a success
students for your inspiration you can
watch more right here on the playlist as
a whole playlist of them to what you'll
notice is every single winner on a
Wednesday always starts with them coming
to my two day crash course so if you
would like to be a winner on a Wednesday
literally come on my crash course and
who knows in three months time you could
be here in my offices on this show as a
winner on a Wednesday so get yourself
booked on the crash course watch more
have fun I'll see you next week